so my talk will be a little bit easier after that great introduction um
so i'm gonna be talking about one of our uh autoimmune CAR-T trials um in in multiple
sclerosis briefly talking about the trial but also just generally uh our experience in in the
autoimmune space these are my disclosures highlighting the the first one that's relevant
to this talk uh so multiple sclerosis affects over a million people in the united states
out of which 30 or 35 percent have progressive forms of the disease either primary or secondary
progressive which is characterized by accumulation of neurologic deficits and disability
ms is driven it's multifactorial but it's driven at least in part by pathogenic cns resident b
cells which is evidenced by histopathologic studies of these patients where they have seen
ectopic lymphoid aggregates in the parenchyma and meninges as well as abnormal
antibody production in the csf which is measurable with these oligoclonal bands
and also elevated igg levels the other evidence for that is the efficacy of ocralizumab a cd20
directed antibody which is approved for progressive ms however despite continuous
therapy with ocralizumab which is given continuously every six months 15 of patients
with relapsed ms and 40 of patients with primary progressive ms will still have progressive
disability or cognitive impairment
uh and other treatments uh have limited uh efficacy
which has led to this the rationale for this study which is that CAR-T cells may
cd19 CAR-T cells may deplete cns resident b cells more effectively than monoclonal antibodies
and there are case reports uh suggesting efficacy of autologous cd19 cartes in ms
which was mentioned in the previous talk
the present um study uses kyv 101 which is a fully human autologous cd19 directed CAR-T cell
product with the cd28 co-stimulatory domain and we hypothesize that this will achieve cns
penetration and in patients with progressive ms and it'll be safe and effective the primary
objectives were to evaluate just cns penetration and preliminary safety
secondary objectives include target engagement based on oligoclonal bands and igg index which is
the measure of csf igg to serum igg safety measures including disease activation or
immune reconstitution pharmacogenetic kinetics and biomarkers and then efficacy
based on the expanded disability status scale and patient reported outcomes
so to study this we designed this is an investigator initiated single center phase 1b
ascending dose study looking at two different dose levels so patients will get um standard flusi lympho
depletion followed by the CAR-T infusion at two different dose levels with five patients per cohort
eligibility includes primary secondary ms with progressive symptoms despite at least one year
prior treatment with either siponimod or an anti-cd20 antibody which are the two approved
therapies uh we're including patients with an edss of three to seven uh just for your reference this
goes up to ten patients with an edss of seven will be ambulatory for less than five meters
without assistance patients with an edss of three will be ambulatory but with various
disabilities including bowel bladder incontinence cognitive disabilities
cognitive deficits and others and you can see on the bottom right the kind of the flow chart of the
patient's uh you know uh pathway so screening apheresis ld chemo um kyv infusion uh inpatient
monitoring up to day seven followed by csf and mris up to uh day up to week 48. so we've treated
uh two patients who've completed their one year of follow-up so far um the first was diagnosed with
relapse remitting multiple sclerosis in 2003 progressed to secondary progressive ms or
converted to secondary progressive ms in 2022 and had a rising edss up to six in 2024 despite
alcoholism map therapy uh followed by enrollment on the trial the second patient was diagnosed
with relapse remitting ms in 1997 and was treated with multiple drugs including interferon
dimethyl fumarate rituximab ocrelizumab but had progression of disability in 2024
followed by enrollment on the trial at that time both of these patients
had detectable CAR-T expansion which peaked at around day 10 which you can see in the middle
okay which you can see in the middle uh curves there um and we were able to detect CAR-T sub
cells in the csf shown on the right you can see the csf in and peripheral blood compartments and
there were detectable CAR-T cells there these studies were done by sasha gupta or neurology
the neurologist who's co-leading the study as far as safety so patient one had no crs or icans
expected cytopenias which recovered fairly quickly grade 3 transaminitis and grade 3 morbilliform
rash which developed on day 32 which was suspected to be CAR-T related there was a lymphocytosis at
that time but uh it was not car positive it was a polyclonal um so unclear uh but most likely related
in some way to the CAR-T given the timing and ongoing grade two hypogammaglobulinemia patient
two had grade one crs neither patient had icans and then expected uh cytopenias which
resolved with supportive care and you can see the recovery of uh b cells on the right there where
you really see improvement at around week 24 after the infusion for efficacy we did see no worsening
of the disability so if you look at the expanded disability status scale on the left we don't
necessarily expect to see improvement because the demyelinating lesions are there but we would hope
to see no worsening these patients actually did improve a bit on their objective measures
looking at the oligoclonal bands and igg index in the middle patient
one uh actually cleared their oligoclonal bands and it went uh to zero uh and it's remained zero
through the end of study uh patient two had uh unquantifiably high levels to at baseline so it
was over five and it remained uh over five but if you look at at the bottom of the igg index
normal is uh less than seven and elevated uh level is consistent with that mass and you can see that
uh patient two had as there's some fluctuation but decreased a bit at the end of study and
both patients had improvement in their 500 meter walk uh compared to pre-treatment and end of study
which you can see on the right so to summarize uh i should say that this was planned for 10
patients the sponsor unfortunately has had problems with manufacturing and so i think our
study is probably going to end up being a case series but based on what we have learned it seems
to achieve cns penetration and target engagement some evidence of target engagement with oligoclonal
bands and and largely expected toxicity profile except for this one patient so even though we had
to cut this study short we've learned a lot i think about how to collaborate with our colleagues so
you know this comes up a lot how we're partnering with other groups
and i'll be brief here but essentially the patients are identified by neurology we then
have a shared consent visit so they talk about the ms part i talk about the aphoresis and CAR-T part
and shared eligibility assessments based on fact criteria etc and then hematology
kind of takes over uh for the aphoresis ld chemo CAR-T infusion and short-term monitoring up to day 30
after the short-term side effects resolve we kind of send the patients back to neurology
and this is my last slide um future directions i think there are a lot of unanswered questions
so first of all will allogeneic cartes be more effective you know autoimmune indications may
not require as much karate expansion or persistence compared to malignancy so
there may be a role for aloe cartes in this setting do we need ld chemo i think dr schuster
brought up this uh point yesterday you know again we may not need as much persistence or expansion
of cartes in this setting we have another iit that we're doing now with a homegrown CAR-T in
which we're omitting ld chemo actually so that should start later this year and then how do we
optimally partner with other disease groups i think you know there are a lot of uh questions
about long-term monitoring and things like that with rheumatologists and neurologists who aren't
as familiar and may not be checking cdc's regularly and so having a good follow-up plan uh
is going to be important uh the astct recently convened a panel
to write up a best practices and that manuscript is under review now so thanks